[Music]
it's me
pewdiepie hey you were my head your
camera
edgar all right activate edgar cam
what a lot of people don't know is that
edgar is actually from russia isn't that
right edgar
da vernon
so today we're reviewing what it's like
in edgar's neighborhood where does he
come from
where does he go just on every day in
russia
let's freaking do this right egger
[Music]
not exactly what you want to see coming
into land at a russian airport
welcome to russia sometimes plain land
sometimes plain crash
we cannot heal it's not the our problem
they have like black planes in russia
too that's so cool
this is what happens if you don't pay
water bill in russia
you must pay water bill
or else water drink you
in mother russia water drinks you enjoy
very flavorful somewhere in russia we
have a real cyber truck
wow looks so squared
is it really russia come on wow
go so fast what's the russian version of
elon musk
[Music]
our favorite billionaire he make money
from slave slavery again i need to be
cute
come on say something funny in russian
you're only here for views that's the
only reason i keep you around so do your
goddamn job
stop falling asleep he's always falling
asleep when i make videos
okay you're touching my keyboard hey
guys stop falling asleep
you're falling asleep again stop it
pewdiepie terrorizes his dog
it's okay in russia we do this all the
time sorry girls i suck
dicks wait i thought there was no gay in
russia what so confused what you say
about this edgar
statistically no gay russia it's crazy
coincidence
the evolution of the bmw 5 series all
right
it's changed throughout the year to
adapt lada perfect from start
we hit the perfect lada it's a good
net change
you want lada yes of course we give you
lada good lad
is that true i kind of want to get a
ladder we hit it out of the park from
the start
lada was the first bill in the soviet
union in 1970
and spawned a thousand playground jokes
but ended up selling more than
what you make fun of lada ow lada make
fun of you
outsell ended up selling more than 20
million worldwide
almost two-thirds of ladas went on to be
sold outside of russia
third wow what is a lot that go for
they're quite rare dude they don't sell
them anymore
russian cops get interrupted by a pack
of wolves
[Music]
it was it was me and my family that was
me my family my family
shut up doug you don't speak bring me
back to russia please
i hated your feelings i just want to
sleep
please let me sleep russian hands-free
trunk opening feature
i have that on my volvo actually
it's super annoying because i always
have to keep kicking it
yeah all right see i i would honestly
have that ladder superior car
it's better
plus 10 holy damage dude look at this
dude
they're all so serious about it i love
it we bless the guns
extra ammunition the guns get plus 15 to
30 damage against demonic enemies only
doom slayer intensifies
greta after week in russia what the [ __ ]
why you don't care about environment
anymore no
i just want a ladder russia opened a
military disneyland called patriot park
where visitors including children can
ride in tanks shoot guns
and buy and sell military gear boys i'm
moving to russia that sounds so much
better than disneyland do you want to go
do you want to go edgar you want to go
you want to go he wants to go look at
him he's so excited
you want to go right we should think yes
look how happy looks
i knew it there's some testosterone in
you after all
gun designs ak-47 ak-47 but small
ak-47 but you need to go pew pew pew
ak-47 but dudes are way over there
[Music]
this was accurate russian trend in
versus the world i've ever seen
all right what do we got almost got away
with it if it wasn't for this slow
elevator
what is happening
it was the cops no so close
one one's gotta sacrifice it wait what
is happening
come on go boys go oh this slow ass
elevator
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
why am i rooting for the criminals only
in russia man
that's hilarious radiger isn't that
funny huh
you're enjoying this video ah the yearly
cleaning of the rocket launcher no
tambourine present
disappointed another day in russia i
suppose
whoa
again we could be doing this let's go to
disneyland in russia
oh [ __ ] well done son
hey we have edgar campbell we don't have
g fuel cam what the [ __ ]
dude type edit editing g fuel cam
immediately
ah yes
that's good you want some you want some
g fuel child
drink it drink it
yes don't be afraid don't be
we are not going firing tanks dumbass
hello do you believe in god
why do i get this feeling like that the
concept of getting sued
just doesn't exist in russia
oh my god what the [ __ ] no
mess is trying to take out trash no no
hello i make cement while you make
dinner i make cement
no problem yes they say lata never
change
model but it does look it's different
i identify as sexy elevator door
once in the elevator this means
backing the patient
[Music]
do you remember that anger did that ever
happen to you how are you so tired
huh you're tired just lazy i don't even
know your video is so boring
i go sleep sleep
i know the way ever since child i've
known them away somehow
mother the priest's airborne the city
with holy water
yo he's just pouring regular water and
like i thought what
what you can't
no you can't just air by people right
here
no what is this
everyone's hit oh my god he went on the
left of it
oh my god dude
[Music]
no
it's okay we fixed oh my god
[Music]
oh jesus christ
does anything ever get done in russia
then damn that was infuriating huh
are you not angry looking at that egg
oops almost missed my exit
oh oh
no no you idiot
oh oh look he got his exit what's that
yeah yes lada took me there it's no
problem
whoopsie whoopsie daisy almost made the
wrong turn
yeah yeah oh my god dude
[Music]
i can't believe that he just took off uh
no that is not what he's saying all
right russian bros i need a trance
same place tomorrow that's a [ __ ]
they made funny subtitles but it's still
insane his lack of
care
he's standing in front of his car spawn
of course they're gonna jump out like
that
moscow police arrest man protesting in
red square with a blank sign
he said too much capture him get him
he's dangerous
propaganda western propaganda we must
stop him
russia russia and russian movies russia
in video games this is
so true
oh dude just wait until you see uk
you came with in movies oh well how
lovely
quite frankly i believe that the
buckingham palace is the nicest
oh [ __ ] coffee what the [ __ ] that's
right you guys the trashiest place i've
ever been to
uh russian shot
[Music]
[Laughter]
i want one i want a russian shot russian
man doesn't give a damn about bear
roaming nearby
the bear has quite the balls to approach
a russian like that
we decide the stair go up and then go
down
because uh [ __ ] i did wrong whoever
built this
big brain big brain russian architect
super strong super tight hey hey stop
yawning
my god dude father sunday i tried to
take him to read it
he doesn't appreciate huh
you tasting the air or something you can
bait that [ __ ]
sad day we lost pure pruskin that day
for por fellow it's not how big your
tool is
oh [ __ ]
is
yeah i heard about that wait what but
the mass is quite dense and yielding to
a drill
so this is what came out of the
chernobyl disaster this like splurge of
melted radioactive uh the mass is quite
dense
unyielding to a drill but able to be
damaged by a kalashnikovs
it can still be someone tried it hey
look at that it's quite
dense radioactivity
how do you know that i want to
understand it wait you're telling me
there's this mass that if anyone's it's
so
radioactive that is if anyone is in the
same room that is they will die
but someone's thought to themselves
that's quite dense but
can it can we shoot it russian mr beast
was like
can this radioactive material
kalashnikov me withstand if a video get
um
one million one mario
is there russian mr visa has to be
what's with bears why does everyone have
a paris pet in russia
[Music]
oh it's cute it's like you had guys
i don't i wouldn't do that
you do it again hey you did
the attitude from this dog man
unbelievable
well that's just another day in russia
if you enjoyed the video smash
like subscribe now for more epic videos
like this one you enjoy
yes right edgar and see you tomorrow
subscribe
bye bye
all right you can go now wait barry is
still level one
and you haven't fed bob god damn
sickness
get only 19 year olds because their new
trials mode
is like use your full pixeling roosters
to defeat as many enemy waves as
possible
download pixel links instantly for 20
muscle increase oh